[Music]
you just shot a movie with a director
Michael Bay yeah and you play is this
right a former bodybuilder well the part
was yeah yeah of course bodybuilder you
had that look again former no it was
written for that but then when they
they'd when I got cast they changed it
to a former amateur wrestler you know
like the yeah why yeah yeah it looks
good with a shirt on yeah and and it was
yeah so it's a totally different what's
it like working with Michael Bay I don't
believe I've met that guy yeah a lot of
people you know he's got a reputation
for being a hard-ass and kind of tough
and and he I saw him make three people
cry in one hour but I to his sort of
he's very honest you know like like I
hate it when directors will come up to
me after your take and say something
like so how did you think that went
you know I don't know how to change my
performance with that know right and so
he but he goes yeah Rob you uh you
improv the joke and it tanked you got
distracted and then you messed up my
line so go back and do it again I was
like thank you that's exactly what
happened now I get it and I know what to
do so yeah I enjoy myself alright well
we have a I wanna make sure we get to
this film you're seeking a friend for
the end of the world now you were in
this movie and I'm told that you're in
this movie for a grand total of how many
minutes you think I've been on this
stage longer than I'm in the movie I
probably like I'm in the trailer for
almost as long as I'm in the movie like
a two minute I'm good for two minute
chunks that's where you were that's
where you do your best work that's where
I really shine okay we we have a clip
here from seeking a friend for the end
of the world
yeah anything you can tell us about this
this is like our kind of a road movie at
the end of the world it's gonna end in
two weeks right and asteroids coming
asteroids
Steve Carrell and Keira Knightley take a
road trip and we are sort of the first
stop me and Connie Britton who plays my
wife Patton Oswalt's is already also in
the scene and uh and we are just sort of
the first like one example of how people
react and it's sort of hedonistic 'le
alright let's take a look at this clip
from seeking a friend for the end of the
world
enjoy Karen Amalfi is coming along don't
do not you know what
please Waring can we just have a few
sober moments tonight this is the last
supper Diane you think Jesus was sober
for his last supper I think you turned
water into lemonade dodge a little help
please
ah no no no no Dodge is my friend my
friend look at this my friend this is a
Don Ramon cigar this is the hardest
cigar in the world can you chop those a
little louder please
this is the hardest cigar in the world
to find and tonight I'm gonna share one
of my last 13 with you
[Applause]